(audience cheers)
- All right, y'all we're back
and hanging out with Terry,
Sophia, Heidi, and Simon
from America's Got Talent.
(audience applauds)
Okay well, our next guest
is all about basking in ridiculousness.
He creates all sorts of cool, crazy,
and utterly pointless products.
All in the name of fun
and experimentation.
They are Unnecessary Inventions.
(upbeat music)
♪ Unnecessary ♪
♪ Inventions ♪
♪ So unnecessary ♪
- [Kelly] So unnecessary.
(laughs)
Let's welcome back to the show,
Matty Benedetto, y'all.
(audience cheers)
- Thank you for having me.
- Hello! Yeah, so it's great to see you!
Meet everyone.
- Hello.
Hello everyone.
Great to see you guys.
- [Simon] Very nice to meet you.
- [Kelly] Okay.
So what do we, what have
you brought us today?
- So the very first invention we have here
was inspired by my sister.
She's got a four year
old and a six year old.
They love playing with Lego.
- [Kelly] Right?
- They just don't love cleaning them up.
- [Kelly] Why?
And then they-
- [Matty] And then they step on them.
- And then they try and like
move on to the next one.
I'm like no you have to pick
this one up before going-
- [Matty] Right now, right here.
- [Kelly] to that one. Yeah.
(Simon laughs)
- And then there's an
episode of The Office where
David Wallace invents the "Suck It".
And so it's sort of this all in one,
(laughter)
- [Simon] The what?
- [Matty] it's this all-in-one
vacuum for,
- [Sophia] The "Suck It?
- [Matty] for the kids, you know,
they they gotta clean
up their toys, you know.
it's a way to
kind of help them
- [Kelly] It's a great
name for any kind of toy.
- Okay.
Keep going.
(audience laughs)
- [Matty] I, so I took those two ideas
- [Simon] Isn't that
called a vacuum cleaner?
- and combined them
and here we have the Lego Suck It.
- Okay
- You know, so,
so let's see Kelly.
- Okay.
We have some Lego here.
You want pass them out.
- [Kelly] Yes, Legos.
- You guys want grab some handful,
- [Kelly] Grab some Legos.
- You know,
just sprinkle them down here.
- Get Legos.
Legos. I'm passing out, I'm passing it.
- You gotta, you gotta
you gotta throw them on the
floor so I can clean them up.
- Oh!
- Oh I got it
- Oh I didn't.
- How about that?
- Oh!
There we go.
Just like that.
Beautiful.
- Just like that.
- This is a nightmare.
It's 3D printed these brackets
that attach attach to a ShopVac.
So the holes progressively get smaller.
So it also sorts the Legos by the size.
- (Simon) Oh wow.
- As you clean it up.
So if we go ahead and turn it
on we can clean up the Lego
and they go ahead and they fall down
and sort the Lego by
size as you set them up.
- [Heidi] Okay.
- Now not only where your
kids, you know, clean them up,
then you also have them organized
for the next time you play.
- I gotta be honest with you too.
My kids would love this whole contraption.
I'd probably get them to clean.
- [Simon] Actually,
it's a good idea.
I might actually, can I buy it?
- [Kelly] It's a good idea.
- Well, how much?
- All right is this shark tank now?
Or am I pitching shark tank.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Simon] I just would like it.
- [Kelly] But wait, do you like that
you know that none of us knew.
We, we know we didn't have to pick it up.
So all of us were like, yep.
- [Matty] I'm done.
Not my problem.
- Yeah.
Okay.
We're gonna look to see what
number it is, but what's next.
I wanna see what's next.
- [Matty] So the next one we
have, as we move down here,
- [Kelly] Here we go.
- [Heidi] We can do it.
- Yeah, watch your step
with all the legos.
- Okay.
Yeah.
Just don't die.
(Simon laughs)
- [Matty] And so the next
invention was inspired
by that feeling of dropping your phone
and you're just like, oh,
please don't be broken.
So here we have the Bungee Saver Max.
So I made a few of them. (Terry laughs)
- [Heidi] I love the look of this already.
- So here, here, Terry,
I got one for you, Heidi.
We've got one for you, Simon.
Here you go.
- [Sophia] I want one.
- [Matty] Would you like to try one?
- I want one too.
- [Simon] We're all doing one?
- [Matty] Let's do it.
- I want one,
help them further.
I guess.
I'm a host.
- [Sophia] I'll help Heidi.
- Okay. We'll do a tag team over here.
- [Kelly] Okay.
And I'll do one.
- [Matty] And then
we've got one more here.
- [Kelly] Oh I love that
you grab blue for me.
- And so it's sort of like
putting on a life jacket,
you know, you just put
your head up through it
Put your arms, arms through the,
I know really confusing.
- You put it the right.
- [Matty] Heidi got it perfect.
- [Heidi] Yeah.
- [Matty] And then you can
tighten it down with some Velcro.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I was like, wait a minute.
- Okay.
- I got it all right.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- So we've got a bungee cord here.
- [Sophia] You need help?
- I'm good, I'm good.
- [Matty] You don't.
you look, perfectly fine.
- I'm good.
Look at that.
- And then you're just like, what?
- [Matty] So yeah.
So you know, you're
walking down the street.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You have a bunch of lego.
Oh, you're not paying attention.
And it bounces right back up.
The person has no idea.
- You know, just bounce right back up.
- [Kelly] Wait, this could,
- Oh I dropped my phone.
- this could also oh
- [Sophia] You're going
to hit your head with it.
(Terry laughs)
- This could also.
- He's working on it.
- [Simon] This one is really stupid.
- [Kelly] This one is.
- [Matty] Thank you.
(everyone laughs)
- I wouldn't buy this one.
(Matty laughs)
- [Sophia] Try it.
- [Kelly] Except you could
attach it to a dog or a child
as well.
- You know, and maybe you're
traveling, anti thefts.
No, one's gonna steal this
phone off you in the city is
- [Heidi] The look of
this, the look is epic.
- I actually don't like it.
- [Heidi] The look is very good.
- [Matty] He's over it.
- [Kelly] Okay.
He's over it.
We're moving on., we're moving on.
- [Matty] We're moving on.
- [Kelly] Okay, we've got one more,
right?
- Yep.
Thank you, thank you.
So we can just put these all here.
- Okay.
- So then the last invention
I have, so picture this,
your, you know,
- [Terry] Yeah.
- I gotta get this off.
- [Terry] Can't get it out?
- Okay, so imagine that you're eating
a really messy food.
You know, your hands
are getting all greasy,
but there's not a napkin insight.
- [Sophia] Oh.
- So you know, you just go
for the pants real quick.
- 100%.
- [Heidi] Oh.
- And I've been wearing my
invention this entire time.
So these are the sloppy slacks.
- [Terry] Yeah.
My kids read that.
- They're the first pants
with high absorbent towels
fills right in.
- That.
- [Matty] So your hands are
messy and you go right in.
Some, some Buffalo wings I think would be
a great way to, to show these off.
- [Heidi] Love some wings.
- [Terry] Yes.
- [Kelly] Oh.
So, okay.
- You know, you got Buffalo
wings. You're getting in there.
Your hands are getting really
gross. You know, you got,
the ranch.
- [Kelly] How in the hell do
you eat wings like that son?
- [Matty] And now you just go ahead.
You wipe them off.
- [Terry] Yeah!
- [Matty] But the best part,
the best part is that
maybe you have a function.
You just go ahead and hide them.
- [Terry] Oh, that's.
- You might smell like chicken wings
but your hands are generally clean.
- [Terry] That is so disgusting.
- [Sophia] Ew.
- Does this thing work on human beings?
(Kelly laughs)
I don't like that idea.
- [Terry] Smell like chicken wings.
- And I want to gift him a pair of them.
- [Simon] No, I want this.
Don't want those.
- Okay, so Matty,
I understand that you've
also invented a board game.
Can people buy it?
- [Matty] Yes.
So it just launched.
So I've been working on this for a while.
It's sort of like Pictionary
meets, Shark Tank.
- [Simon] I like that.
- So you get a, a deck
of cards that have some
first world problems on it.
Like how do I keep the
my pillow cold all night
or that little line
of dust on a dust pan, you
know, trying to clean it up.
- [Kelly] What do you do with it?
- [Matty] What do you do with it?
- [Kelly] I know.
(Simon laughs)
- [Matty] And so now you
have two minutes to come up
with a brand new invention.
- [Kelly] I just sweep it under something.
- You get a dry erase board.
You have to come up with a
picture of the invention.
- [Heidi] Okay.
- A name for it.
And then, you know, shark
tank style, you have
to pitch your invention
idea to the whole group.
Everyone votes on who solved
that problem the best.
And then that person wins
the round and you move
on to the next problem.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- [Terry] Yeah.
- [Kelly] I like it.
I like it.
All right. Thank you so much,
Matty, for joining us again.
Everybody you can pick
up Unnecessary Inventions
the game on Matty's site,
Amazon and selected retailers.
We're gonna give Simon a Lego suck back
because well, he's awesome.
And that's what, why
not celebrate 20 years
with a Lego pickup vacuum.